47 seconds of logos accidentally exposed
to retrovirus
alz 113 backstory exposition by newscast
montage
you mean Godzilla or x-men United which
famous incident are you talking about a
six-hour standoff with police okay come
on I know that movies reduced time but
there is absolutely no way that the
standoff and rise happened for six hours
CDC is projecting a fatality toll
ranging from five million to as many as
a hundred and fifty million so almost
every number then thanks CDC thundering
lightning indicates something ominous
cliche Andy Serkis isn't winning an
Oscar in this scene good to see that the
Apes have learned basic expositional
sign language when has a son in a movie
ordered to stay ever not wandered away
huh maybe the ecosystem has changed a
bit but a random bear showing up in
Northern California after the last known
bear was shot and killed there in 1922
seems like you're adding conflict for
the hell of it well there goes the
entire bear population in California
again let's face it the only reason
Cesar's kid got scarred so we'd know
what 20 is Apes cool
apparently apes have learned you need to
wear surgical masks during childbirth
but they have not learned that a hundred
eight doctors are not needed in this
situation also thank God Cesar's bear
fight ended in time for him to arrive
home just as his son is being born yes
we definitely want the older son with
gaping bloody wounds approaching the
baby with no immune system definitely
why is there one asshole walking far far
ahead of the entire group
is it so that this guy can panic and
shoot one of these Apes man do you think
they understand what you're saying does
it look like just Apes tail um yeah kind
of I mean their organization is a little
scary but do I think they would
understand English if you spoke it to
them it's just like if you ran into a
giant group of Germans in the woods
you'd expect them to know English this
guy drops his bag for no damn reason
other than the plot it's not like that
thing was sloppily slung on his shoulder
and fell off like I was holding it yeah
no need for you Kong until the Empire
State Building finale he could
she did maybe he kept us alive so they
could follow us double team pronoun game
movie saves money by using real shots of
San Francisco streets in place of
post-apocalyptic ones are we supposed to
believe these assholes swung their way
across the redwoods and the Golden Gate
Bridge faster than their car and weren't
seen okay they're going into the city
some are even riding horseback this must
have been quite the scene at the
checkpoint near the Golden Gate Bridge
but hey those guys am i right
also why are some of these assholes
running across rooftops you basically
have to enter the city and say you know
I think I'll travel by rooftop it's more
jumpy that way a guy with no context for
why the number 80 was chosen earlier
decides to chastise the other guy for
not estimating the hidden amount of apes
from a previous scene better by the way
have I mentioned that Keri Russell is
not my girlfriend in the scene do not
come back um can we talk about the dam
for a second before you leave damn it I
just created extra conflict for this
movie I realize you don't have power but
you could have sent a party to any
number of cities a long-ass time ago you
don't think there are other pockets of
immune people just like you all over the
place
we're two weeks away from running out of
fuel you waited that long before
exploring the dam and any other power
options are you kidding what if it
backfires what if he gets filed I mean
how do you know that if you even
understand you did you not hear Caesar
shouting English a minute ago I mean
being in denial earlier sort of made
sense but now you've witnessed it with
your own eyes son it's not safe I'm
safer with you that ham down here
this guy is trying to prevent war so
that he can protect his girlfriend and
son but decides bringing them along on
the possibly insane go talk to Caesar
plan is somehow a decent idea I know
don't come back I know I've had two
chances to talk to you about this damn
dam but coming back here risking my life
sounded like the better option I could
just show you anyone
why not just say we're all going to die
without power and that damn nearby can
provide the power why the unnecessary
mystery in an already tense situation
yeah you have a little girl Carver that
you know how'd she die that's enough for
your wife for that matter Colville you
better shut up before I kick your ass
I'm the asshole these people let him
walk away without telling him that yes
he's the asshole they are keeping watch
over the humans they don't trust and are
bringing newborn babies alone well I
didn't question is why don't you get
gary oldman in on this decision since he
just happens to be here right now shall
I shoot him yeah one son of a bitch
aren't despite evidence that these Apes
speak English these assholes still say
this stuff brace yourself
why don't you let them get out of here
before you blow this thing up hell you
don't even give it any thought you're
just like well no more wire better blow
this thing up right now without thinking
did they not tell the Apes explosions
were involved unsupervised children of
course there's a gun in this thing so
many reasons not to let this child run
over here in the first place so many
ways of stopping him but everyone goes
momentarily stupid so that this can
happen you know wow this is exactly what
was said to me after my first sexual
encounter Wow so he's also going to
return home at the exact moment his wife
is dying and Cesar has some convenient
ass timing all so sudden Caesar's wife
is 6 subplot is sudden but thank God
right how much would the humans carry
favor if they didn't bring medicine with
Malcolm where are you going
uh there's no time to explain H just
take Malcolm up to Caesars Palace no
problem thankfully I brought my
postpartum monkey get better medicine
with me in my bag on the big restart the
damn mission isn't it sort of dumb to
talk about such things in the communal
ape gathering place while using sign
language this is a terrible shooting
gallery there's only one target and it's
so damn big and close I'm wondering what
the point is and wasting all this ammo
contributing to the delinquency of an
ape okay with these assholes weren't
idiots and we're completely drunk and
had even 20% of the normal reaction
these afraid of apes San Francisco
humans have demonstrated so far none of
the rest of the movie could happen okay
Koba you've gone too far your anger at
humans is justified and your complicated
character full-on gray-colored up until
now the point you light your own
civilization on fire just a further your
agenda shame on you Koba I've half a
mind not to give you any monkey treats
tonight well it's a good thing Caesar
was standing in the perfect place where
Koba could shoot him without anybody
seeing it came to a town with a plan and
man did it work out beautifully without
any time wasted and a spy tickler
gunshot noise Caesar's son and wife do
not immediate
jump to the edge to see who did it
instead they hug which is also that by
the time the Sun actually looks Koba has
escaped somehow even though we saw
earlier that Caesars home was apparently
high up above most of the rest of the
common area but whatever is the tank
shot coming soon God despite widespread
distrust in the humans and blue eyes
yelling human gun none of the Apes looks
up to where Malcolm is and does anything
to prevent their escape ah everyone just
accepts that Caesar is dead without
looking for a body
I believe they'd still believe the lie
anyway but not even Koba checks to make
sure he's dead before rallying the
troops to fight the human city
furthermore Koba makes his announcement
without setting up guards to prevent
Malcolm and his crew from running away
in the first place
and now that I've looked at this shot
again where the what's Koba even
supposed to have been standing when he
made that shot let alone the easy escape
ah the under the log hiding place is
there everytime you need it
how many places like this do you think
exist in nature enough to be convenient
wait how long has power been restored
his iPad is just now figuring this out
thank God they got the electricity
working so the perimeter dudes could
radio you about the incoming ape attack
am i right that was convenient
yeah California Street okay look nearly
all these apes have never shot a gun
before but they're one handing some
serious machinery without any kickback
whatsoever like they're all natural-born
Rambo's Koba and Caesars kid gets shot
off their horses but apparently bullets
aren't apes what negative press is to a
kardashian KO but does his best Dances
with Wolves impression and similarly it
does not get shot thankfully this weary
human civilization keeps all their
barrels of fuel outside the city walls
otherwise this battle scene would be
missing one awesome explosion you
wouldn't think an ape on a horse could
charge a tank without dying but you'd be
wrong I gotta admit this shot right here
is beautiful gotta remove a sin for it
we're not made of stone although now
that I think about it who's driving the
spinning tank to this perfect location
right now eventually the fire raging
over wooded leaves
um put itself out apparently score how
in the is Caesar all the way down here
did he get shot and then dragged himself
all the way to this spot and it's a
major convenience he shows up right in
front of them as they're about to find
the car has anyone out here ever lifted
one of these things what this dude is
doing is cooking impossible unless he's
Lou Ferrigno and he doesn't look like
Lou Ferrigno so I'm calling some major
Bulls right here all these apes most who
still believe in Cesar's teachings allow
Koba to do this this rule was on their
wall for
sake eggs go from kill all humans to
shepherd them like prisoners of war with
no explanation but it sure helps keep
the body count down heavy-handed shot of
Koba standing on the tattered American
flag is heavy-handed and that James
Franco finds his way into every movie
doesn't he even ones where he's presumed
dead we need to operate I don't have
anything geez why did we blindly go
wherever Caesar wanted to go without the
tools needed to fix Caesar and stop the
war you know like bein in the Dark
Knight Rises these Apes are still taking
prisoners they simply do not need an
Turkey Apes just happen to be doing
stupid shit in the exact place where
Malcolm needs to get surgical tools
extraordinary set of circumstances allow
this guy to stay unseen by Abe's camera
movement is reliable in telling you that
there's probably a bad guy just around
the corner that he's not seeing cliche
fortunately for Malcolm and the plot the
eight that sponson hiding is caesar's
conflicted son so all is good for the
intended plot carry on look I get it
he thinks humans did this but does it
not occur to him that these particular
humans definitely didn't hurt him and
they wouldn't take him all the way here
to give him medical attention
I guess these apes evolved crying in ten
years did becoming intelligent mean
their physiology changed Oh Elsie first
I should probably wash this blood off my
hands
but since I'm already here what the hell
let's talk about things this camera
works after ten years of not being used
the camera just happens to have a
recording of Caesars first days of youth
and innocence cued up and ready for
dramatic effect also it has 42 minutes
of battery life after ten years of not
being used get the fuck out of here even
if it was being charged when the power
came back on
should I be fully charged if that's the
case yes your son is not bad kid no but
he'll be here in a minute on cue just
because you're talking about it
that's why I blindly fired my gun
instead of yelling this warning in the
first place not misfortunate that he
runs through the subway tunnel that
leads directly to Dreyfus who just so
happens to be planning the blow up the
very tower Caesar is climbing right now
the Apes that took over the tower never
bothered to investigate the lower levels
of said Tower or even look down we need
to give him the chance we need to give
him some time he's up there right now
holding three minute gunpoint is the
perfect time to play the pronoun game
three times three times for three guys I
guess Caesar is walking out there with
no gun and staring down a dude with a
gun let's just all take a moment to
appreciate the ballsy badassness that is
Caesar can we Caesar
wait Copa week r8 measuring contest
eating the Apes succumb to the siren
song of settling things with fisticuffs
trust Caesar
brother Doge oh my it's a good thing
they've gotten better at speaking since
the beginning of the movie can you
imagine if they had a sign language each
other through this fight Oh funny how
the good human banned human faceoff
occurs exactly when the good eight bad a
face-off is occurring just kooky now we
make contact a military base up north I
think they're already on their way
so that's why we strapped c-4 to this
building to blow up all the Apes because
the military's coming to kill all the
Apes wait that is some specie for work
there since the tower didn't remotely
come down he survives this but they both
survive this ah the extended piece of
girder that sticks out of everything
building somehow always there to keep
the drama going if we were ten minutes
away from the end Koval would grab this
cable and hung on for dear life or
landed on this walkway and somehow not
hurt himself or the walkway would movie
ends with the same thing it began with
cliche also what happened to Keri
Russell and Malcolm's kid they just kind
of disappeared I guess they're hanging
out at James Franco's old place watching
Caesar movies or something you stuck
around for the closing credits and all
you got was a bunch of AP gibberish
uh-huh
no no go
maybe we can take it down just a little
I think you're gonna the other pregnant
women because it's the hero Gotham
deserves but not the one it needs right
now
so we'll hunt him sure no you know when
you lie to me I hurt you
I know now why you cry but it's
something I can never do I don't know
the scientific explanation but fire made
it good yes
yeah Wow okay who wants to go down the
creepy tunnel inside the tomb first